hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm and for those of you
that are a fan on the chess group on
facebook we recently asked who your
favorite chess player of all time is and
bobby fischer won by a slim margin over
garry kasparov so i didn't want to make
a video on a game that Bobby Fischer
played but I wanted to choose one that
not many people are familiar with I know
most avid chess players have probably
seen some of the most famous Bobby
Fischer games had be played whether that
was the game of the century or against
Spassky and World Championships but he
did play a lot of other phenomenal games
and so that's kind of what I wanted to
go over in this video one of his many
many famous games that he played that
just shows what a great chess player he
is this game was played between Fischer
and pond opana was a very strong GM he
was from Argentina he was also a World
Junior Chess Champion so a very strong
player in his own right obviously
against Bobby Fischer one of the
greatest chess players of all time not
quite that strong but definitely a very
formidable opponent for Bobby Fischer to
play at this time so we'll go ahead and
get into it Bobby Fischer is playing the
white pieces starts out with pawn to e4
and Ponte responded with pawn to c5 the
Sicilian defense Bobby Fischer decides
to play Knight to f3 and after pawn to
e6 Bobby Fischer likes to play pawn to
d3 this is the Kings Indian attack this
is one of the the many different
openings that Bobby Fischer was very
familiar with and very very strong in he
really understood a lot of the the
tactical and reasoning behind many of
the lines that are commonplace today he
kind of developed him on his own Kings
any attack be him one of those he was
very strong in his own right so we'll go
ahead and continue black now plays
Knight to c6 simple developing move
trying to get his knight to the action
at the same time trying to really hone
down on these dark squares on this d4
and this e v square right here Bobby
Fischer continued with pawn to g3
getting ready to fee and Kenny was
Bishop to the King side and black
decides to do the same thing same thing
with pawn to g6
now Bobby Fischer plays with his bishop
being keto into g2 and black does as
well
Bishop to g7 for those of you that are
familiar with Bobby Fischer style of
play it's always interesting to watch
him in the beginning of the game because
he always develops his pieces so
methodically he usually tries to gain
Center control with his pieces and then
anytime he sort of sees any sort of
weakness and his opponent he just
strikes and he strikes hard I mean it's
very hard to to counter that so just
keep that in mind as we kind of look at
how Bobby Fischer develops all his
pieces and then as soon as he starts to
see a small weakness he just kind of
jumps on that but from here Bobby
Fischer continues with his development
with castling on the kingside and black
obviously has to get his night out the
way he brings his knight to e7 not a bad
move developing his knight also
connecting both his nights here on c6
and e7 at the same time he does want to
keep this long dark diagonal available
for his dark squared Bishop Aran g7 to
attack now Bobby Fischer brings his rook
to e1 you always want to support your
pawns as they move up the board with
your rooks behind them so that's exactly
what he's doing and now black plays pawn
to d6 obviously he wants to add a little
bit of support to his pawn here on c5 as
is weak at the same time he does want to
allow his Bishop here his LightSquared
Bishop to have a square if he ever does
need to come here now Bobby Fischer here
decides to play pawn to c3 getting ready
to push forward with his pawn to d4 me
already does have his night here on f3
he does have a nice little defense for
his King so he really wants to start to
control the center of the board here
especially with his pawn now black does
have two options he can either bring his
pawn to e5 try to attack now he has two
attackers on this d4 square but he does
elect for his other move and that is to
castle on the King side it's never a bad
thing to get King King side safety
although we did have another move to
bring his pawn to e5 right away now from
here Bobby Fischer decided to go ahead
and move forward with this plan with
pawn to d4 again he does have this pawn
on c3 defending this Queen here on d1
and also this night here on f3 all
defending this pawn on D
for now black decides to go ahead and
start to exchange so Bobby Fischer
elects to continue to do that and takes
with his pawn on d4 now black now starts
to push up his pawn on d5 trying to
attack in the center here trying to have
some sort of control and Bobby Fischer
likes to decline this exchange and
instead moves pawn to e5 and this is a
brilliant move because it really puts a
lot of pressure on these dark squares on
the kingside this outpost on f6 is gonna
be a huge weakness for black if white
can ever exchange off this dark square
Bishop and get this key defender of this
f6 square then he can easily put a night
here on f6 it's a great outpost or if he
wants to get another piece involved he
can always sit this here on f6 so this
is a great move especially since black
was trying to control the dark squares
for Bobby Fischer to play this 'if I've
move it really puts a lot of pressure on
black here as most strong players do
they like to develop all their pieces so
black went ahead here and played Bishop
to d7 developing the rest of his minor
pieces Bobby Fischer continued to follow
suit he plays Knight to c3 of getting
all his pieces developed into the game
at the same time trying to get center
control you always want to develop your
minor pieces in the early game towards
the center so they're not only in the
action but they're controlling the
center which is so important in the
early game now from here black decide to
play his rook to c8 you always want to
put your rooks on open files or semi
open files meaning if there's no pawns
or if there's one pawn on a file you
always want your rooks to go there so
this is a great move by black here
putting his rook on CA this is exactly
where he needs to be so that he can be
active and be used as he was meant to be
now Bobby Fischer went ahead and brought
his Bishop to f4 again he really wants
to develop his last minor piece here
thinking about all the different places
that he can bring it he could have
brought it somewhere else but he does
not want to block off his rook here on e
1 obviously he would be blocking off his
Queen here on d2 and he doesn't want to
extend it too far there's no reason to
bring it to h6 and lose it right away
and there's no reason to bring it right
now to G's 5 so he went ahead
brought it to f4 nice safe move
developing but at the same time I'm
getting all his minor pieces into the
game so he can start to get his major
pieces activated it's always hard to
look at a chess game especially at a GM
level with such you know great chess
mind and say you know one specific move
lost a chess game because I think it's a
you know accumulation of a lot of
different moves together a lot of times
is just brilliance from one side but the
next move from black is definitely
questionable he plays Knight to a5 and
while this does open up the C file for
his rook I don't feel like this is a
great move for this night here on a5
it's kind of lessening his his active
piece that he here had here on c6 when I
thought was a fine square kind of
analyzing it it may have been better for
him to bring his Knight to f5 after he
done this after Bobby Fischer brings his
rook to c1 obviously Bobby Fischer wants
to bring his rook to an active file here
on C then black can't even bring you
know his pawn down to h5 trying to
really hold down this square here on g4
if anyone wants to come to this g4
square to kick off this night this night
has a great outpost here on f5 this
would be a fantastic move here obviously
black is now putting a lot of pressure
on the kingside the Bobby Fischer is
gonna have to find some way to combat
this but in the game this is not what
was played instead of this active move
of Knight to f5 instead the knight came
to a5 kind of going away from the action
but really trying to get some action on
the Queen side and kind of forgetting
about the King side right now from here
Bobby Fischer won as we continued he
brought his his rook to c1 obviously
again as we talked about you want your
rooks on open or semi open files and
from here black played pawn to b5 as we
talked about before with his plan of
Knight to a5 he does really want to
expand on the Queen side so that's
exactly what he's doing
and from here Bobby Fischer plays pawn
to b3 obviously he doesn't want you know
black to just completely march up the
board so he's going to try to defend
on the queenside now from here black
continues up the board with pawn to b4
attacking the knight here and so the
knight from Bobby Fischer's gonna come
to e2 here obviously just kind of a
waiting move to see he's obviously
defending this pawn here on d4 but at
the same time as he wants to to free up
the C file for his rook at the same time
kind of wait to see where he point wants
to put this knight here that's on e2
black decides to continue with his
Bishop to b5 which I personally think is
a great move Bishop here on d7 isn't
doing too much and is really starting to
put a lot of pressure with his minor
pieces obviously he's you know attacking
in defending this square here on c4 but
at the same time he's now attacking this
Knight here on e - it's just being a lot
more active than it was here on d7 at
the same time it does free up this Queen
in case he does want to come to this d7
Square now from here Bobby Fischer likes
to play with Queen to d2 and this does a
few things one it attacks this pawn here
on before it also gives a little support
to this Bishop on f4 anytime this Bishop
wants to come to h6 to try to exchange
off these dark square bishop which we
said was good earlier in the game at the
same time he's also defending this
Knight here on e - so any player
especially a player like Bobby Fischer
is going to play a move with multiple
reasoning behind it and so this move of
Queen to d2 really does get his Queen
into the game for for many different
reasons
now from here black decides to bring his
knight back to c6 which is where it
should have been the entire game but
it's there now also it's supporting this
pawn here on b4 as we talked about this
coin is attacking it so obviously you
want to have your pawns and your pieces
protected at all time if they are being
attacked from here Bobby Fischer plays
pawn to g4 and this is kind of a turning
point in the game here Bobby Fischer
kind of looks at the board he sees all
his pieces kind of uniformly connected
and working together and he really wants
to know what he wants to do with this
Knight here on e - it's not really going
to go to c3
be it can't come to d4 obviously it
can't go where the king is the only real
option is for it to come to g3 obviously
this pawn here being on g3 right away
you can't go there so he decides to
really take a stab at attacking the
Kings side this obviously does open up a
little weakness obviously anytime you
you know expand your pawns in front of
your king your King does get a little
weaker but he does have plans of
bringing his knight to g3 now in my
opinion black really only had one move
here although this is not what he moved
I think that he has to play Bishop takes
on e to just kind of looking at what
bobby fischer's plan is obviously you
never want Bobby Fischer to overload all
his pieces on one side because with his
creativity I'm it's just not gonna go
good for you
now later you know paano was asked why
he didn't exchange this and he said that
he didn't want to give Bobby Fischer the
bishop pair after he exchanged his
bishop for a knight if you look at this
game though it is somewhat closed in the
middle so I don't really think the
bishop pair is as strong as Vantage yes
you don't want to give Bobby Fischer
bishop pair but in a close game it's not
as bad in this case I do think though
that black had to play Bishop takes on
e2 buddy didn't em instead he played
pawn to a5 solidifying the defense on
this beef or pawn it at the same time
allowing this night here on c6 which is
the key defender of the pawn on b4 to
move around the board so now he can get
this other Knight involved into the game
now obviously Bobby Fischer's going to
continue his playing as fast as possible
his Knights can not gonna do anything
unless he gets it over to this g3
squares we talked about there's nowhere
else for it to go so Bobby Fischer
immediately plays Knight to g3
black not completely acknowledging or I
guess respecting the attack that Bobby
Fischer is about to just unleash on the
chess board black continues to try to
expand on the queenside by bringing his
Queen to b6 if you can look at it
there's not a lot of great attacking
lines that black has for the Queen side
so it is questionable you know why he
did try to attack on the queenside when
there's not many options at the same
time you see Bobby Fischer start to
materialize an attack on the kingside
but for what it's worth Queen was played
to b6 and Bobby Fischer just decided
that he's going all out and he's going
to take this black King here on g8 so he
plays pawn to h4 just completely
marching up the board he realizes it's
gonna be really hard for his King to be
attacked even though he is pushing these
pawns up because most of the powerful
pieces for black are on the Queen side
so he realizes that he can kind of
overload the King side and dominate and
checkmate the black King here so black
now kind of got the idea that hey I
should probably start to maneuver my
pieces back over to the Kings side and
he plays Knight to b8 at the same time
he's opening up the C file for his rook
but he also wants to kind of maneuver
his knight over to d7 so he can you know
keep an eye on the f6 outpost that we
talked about which is a very critical
square at the same time if he ever needs
to get his knight to the f8 square to
protect this h7 square that will be a
huge weakness later on in the game from
here Bobby Fischer continued with his
plan obviously right now he's trying to
trade off the dark square Bishop as we
talked about once his dark square Bishop
is off the board then this f6 where it
becomes a huge huge focal point as an
outpost the Bobby Fischer can put one of
his pieces most notably a night here on
f6 so black decided to bring his Knight
to d7 as we talked about before no
reason right away to to exchange pieces
instead he really wants to try to get
his knight involved into the game
attacking this f6 Square from here Bobby
Fischer played Queen to g5 just
continuing to put the pressure on black
here he still has a thing the same
concepts in the back of his mind at the
same time now he's now pinning this pawn
and the bishop down to the King so if he
starts to put his pawns up farther he's
still defending this bishop here on h6
but he's just slowly and slowly putting
more and more pressure on black black
now decided to start to exchange pieces
off in
time you start to feel a lot of pressure
it's usually good to exchange pieces off
to kind of give you some breathing room
so black does exactly that he exchanges
on c1 after the rooks come off the board
he now takes the bishop here on h6 and
the queen comes here and then the knight
excuse me the rook comes to c8 and both
the rooks come off the board and now
Bobby Fischer just continues
relentlessly moving his pawns up the
board with pawn to h5 really putting a
lot of pressure on the Kings side from
black now black now played Queen to d8
he probably should have brought you know
his knight to f8 here again I don't
think he realizes just how big of
weakness this pawn here on h7 anytime
Bobby Fischer can bring his Knight to g5
I'm putting a lot of pressure on the
pawn on h7 but in any case he did bring
his Queen to d8 he really wants to get
his Queen involved in the game as you
can see kind of Black's plan was kind of
to attack on the Queen side he started
to use all his moves
I mean his development to bring to the
Queen side and then when he realized you
know oh crap Bobby Fischer is attacking
my Kings side then he said well let me
just kind of backtrack and start to
defend on the Kings side so for what
it's worth white now played Knight to g5
as we talked about before putting a lot
of pressure on this pawn on age 7 and
now black plays Knight to at fate trying
to defend this checkmate here of Queen
to h7 obviously it would have been
checkmate at this you know the King
could come to f8 but Bobby Fischer is
threatening a mate pretty soon here from
here Bobby Fischer has a fantastic
movement it's a Bishop to e4 and the way
this is great is because he obviously
wants to get his LightSquared Bishop
into the game but the same time black
cannot really take with his pawn here on
e4 because after the knight comes to e4
the Knights gonna come to f6 and this is
going to be really hard for black to
defend obviously yes Bobby Fischer
sacrificing a bishop here but after his
Knight comes
to f6 and there's no way for black to
stop this it's pretty much going to be
game over so black knows that he can't
take on e4 so he decides to bring his
Queen to e7 really trying to get his
queen involved in the game try to
protect the house but it's just not
gonna work from here Bobby Fischer plays
Knight takes on h7 and after the night
comes and takes on 87 again he is just
sacrificing pieces because he
understands the threat that he has and
even though he is giving up pieces he
realizes that this bishop here on b5
isn't doing anything and it's not always
how many pieces you have it's how many
active pieces you have attacking your
opponent's king so I always remember
that Bobby Fischer obviously knows that
so we now takes on g6 and after the the
pawn takes on g6 now the bishop is going
to take on g6 you can already see
there's no fortress in front of the
black King here on g8 and Bobby Fischer
is just going to continue at the board
until he checks me checkmates the black
from here black plays Knight to g5 kind
of is a last-ditch effort trying to
start to attack on the King side Bobby
Fischer doesn't really matter for him he
brings his knight to h5 he realizes the
attack from black can't really do much
besides a few attacks here and there and
he realized his attack is completely
strong on this black King on G 8 so from
here the black knight comes to f3 just
trying to harass the white king it's
kind of out of Hope here but decides to
try to attack anyway the King's gonna
come up the board Knights gonna come to
h4 try to check the King again and the
King's just gonna come up the board
obviously the knight now is gonna take
on g6 and this is kind of where Bobby
Fischer shows his brilliance he realizes
a lot of people from here would take
with the Queen on g6 you know the the
Queen could come over now - you know g7
that's kind of what people think what
would happen instead the king can now
come to f8 and then you trying to figure
out you know what you want to do here
instead bobby fisher' doesn't do what
you expect instead he plays Knight to f6
this is a fantastic move because the
Queen can't take because the pawns
supporting it so what is the King do
that the Knights pretty much a goner so
that the King really doesn't have many
options his only move here is his king
to f7 and from here Bobby Fischer plays
Queen to h7 and from here black resigned
he really only has one option here he
can move his you know his king to f8 he
can't move it to a eight or you know GA
because the Queen and the rook or excuse
me the Queen of the Night here um and
from here Bobby Fischer can play Queen
to g8 checkmate so Bobby Fischer never
really looks for the obvious moves he
looks for the best move which is what I
always appreciated studying Bobby
Fischer games so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this game many of you probably
haven't seen this game before so it's
probably a treat for some of you for
those of you who have seen it you're
probably a super chess avid fan which is
fantastic hopefully you guys did enjoy
the video and learn something if you
haven't checked out the website the
choice the chess website calm and I will
see you guys in the next video thanks
for watching